demain il a écrit des chansons pour
sylvie vartan johnny hallyday yves
montand ou encore marie laforêt pourtant
c'est surtout son visage que le grand
public connaît celui d'un comédien qui a
aussi bien joué dans pouic pouic que
dans un film de zulawski cette fois il
revient au théâtre dans une pièce qui
est un petit miracle voici maintenant
l'invité des cinq dernières minutes et
s'est invitée c'est roger dumas bonjour
merci vraiment battre ici avec nous sur
le plateau des cinq dernières minutes
pour nous parler de cette crise qui a
énormément de succès vraiment on est
dans le bonheur total
c'est fragile le succès est tellement
énorme j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie et
les critiques sont bonnes y en a pas une
mauvaise et la tonne alors cette pièce
elle s'appelle l'étudiante et monsieur
henri c'est au petit théâtre de paris
vous partager notamment la fiche avec
claudie a dit mié l age ou l'étudiante
vous voyez monsieur à l a jamais joué
c'est sa première pièce absolument
incroyable c'est candidate pour elle
c'est un ben laden
génial voilà et alors vous n'êtes pas
très commode quand même dans le rôle de
monsieur henri chassé les plus beaux
rôles seul à céder les commandes du raid
rognon les grognons mon père était un
peu comme ça quand il disait football
après ça vous dire je t'aime bien alors
racontez nous un petit peu la pièce
c'est quoi c'est un face à face en
trente deux personnes qui auraient
jamais lanceurs entre quatre personnes
d'ailleurs je dois dire tout de suite
que nous sommes vraiment un quatuor peu
le c'est pas moi qui suis la pièce de la
pièce d'une telle 10 banques calbérac
est un garçon qui a fait des films
formidables irène qui était un très joli
film x e cl de fond et là on est un
quatuor d'abord aux cèpes tous les cas
alors il ya il a fait d'abord vous votre
fils votre belle fille annoncent un jour
mon fils sébastien castro qui est un
garçon dont on a déjà pas mal parlé et
lysiane meis qui fait ma belle fille qui
est une actrice de bagnes et et que les
gens connaissent et qui
composante elle doit jouer ce que les
autres peintres une idiote en réalité
c'est une corde idée de sincère une
femme claire une femme pleine de coeur
balance en bien il ya ce qu à toi qui en
classe mais il ya une situation qui est
très particulière
c'est cette jeune fille elle va venir
habiter chez vous elle elle est
étudiante vous êtes un vieux monsieur
voilà c'est à dire que beaumont mon nom
mon fils ne veut plus que j'habite seul
parce qu'il a peur que j'ai des baleines
et tout ça donc ils me forcent à prog
une étudiante comme colocataire
je suis étudiant et moi je fais tout ce
que je peux quand elles arrivent pour le
dégoûter de l'assemblée de renom non
c'est pas bien il ya des cas par cas
pour fouad en finale monfils il est pas
si l'allemande prend elle pas encore des
plateformes et voilà c'est la
cohabitation avec cette cette jeune
fille et mon fils qui a épousé une femme
comme moi je n'aime pas et je voudrais
que ils sont ses parts pour mona alors
s'étendre c'est fort c'est drôle c'est
un très joli texte
les gens atteints texte magnifique parce
que il ya quelque chose que j'aime les
gens rient sans arrêt sans arrêt
vraiment c'est incroyable
il applaudit des répliques of abu il est
de leur ire et jamais des baux d'auteur
ce sont toujours des rires de situation
voilà alors l'accord on va tout de suite
regardé quelques petits extraits de la
pièce qu'il faut là je crois que vous
l'avez déjà fait en donner envie aux
téléspectateurs d'aller la voir mais en
regardant les extraits on va voir quel
point vous êtes bourgault et un bon goût
très réussie dans la pièce on regarde
ensemble voilà c'est ça et donc il m'a
donné rendez vous avec vous bon mon
abrutis cuisse qui à benoît que lui plus
seule famille jonquet la tête qui tourne
alors ça m'inquiète pour la vérité c'est
que jim burke bonsoir fou depuis le 1er
mai c'est pour les odeurs dans
l'immeuble
j'ai vraiment entrer dati rome avec
votre propre fils peux tu n'es tu es
très mignon mais ça s'est beaucoup
dégradée moi je dis à partir de 40 ans
les responsables de la tête commun
c'est votre fils ça devait être qu'un
abruti jal est devenu au contact de
cette bourde elle est faite à bouffer du
point alors à lyon pas de capoiera c'est
pas forcément de la bêtise ans de la
panique captée par yann cartron guerre
elle sur verts doivent affronter voix à
paul c'est exprès on rit en regardant
les extraits ça c'est quand même très
bon qu'est ce que ça dit qu'on peut
faire mentir l'état civil qu'on peut
regagner des années si c'est un peu ce
qu'on pense en vous voyant pas question
de retraite pour vous un [ __ ] pas
question d'ailleurs vous savez moi je ne
sais même pas quel âge j'ai comme moi je
vis avec une femme plus jeune que moi
chez moi on ne parle pas d'accès
interdit et on ne souhaite pas les
anniversaires
donc les gens disent que j'ai 80 morts
mais vous savez on dit tellement de
choses moi je ne montais revient pas
toujours faire confiance aux gens n'ont
ils pas pu demander des conseils à jean
d'ormesson ou à michel bouquet voilà
mais je les adore moi seul je vous le
dis je vous leur demandez des voisins je
veux être connu voilà je voudrais dire
aussi c'est que j'ai fait une rencontre
magnifique avec ivan calbérac qui m'a
écrit ce rôle
cent mille âmes mais aussi avec les mots
les trois acteurs et quels jeux vous
vraiment c'est le bonheur tous les soirs
on sait mon sens bracquemont bon et puis
j'ai fait la connaissance de josé paul
qui est le metteur en scène que je ne
connaissais pas et dès les premières
phrases qui m'a dit il m'a dit alors
roger ça sera comme ça comme ça et comme
ça je les écoute toi je ferai tout ce
que tu me demandes
c'est un joli petit miracle quoi et je
n'ai jamais discuté une indication
merci à vous vraiment roger dumas on
recommande infiniment cette pièce
rappelle le titre s'appelle l'étudiante
et monsieur henri leurs côtés notamment
de claude a dit mié c'est au petit
théâtre de paris une pièce divan
calbérac mise en scène par josé paul
vous en avait parlé
merci encore de borny aussi infiniment
c'est la fin de ce genre